oh maybe we can see the stockfish  evaluations again because  how narrow is the winning path for white  there are three winning moves at least  maybe more he is winning  so is the rook move maybe a mistake or  is it going to be  which the rick mook moving to the second  row  wow  okay  he's done it but okay so why would this  be a mistake it looks no it looks  completely winning right because  when black tries to push  charlie the sea pawn the king will step  across and we're seeing it look how the  white king and rook are completely  stopping the black pawns and we'll see a  really nice finish here after rook takes  pawn and the black knight is trapped  white's pawn runs through and wins and  he's smiling lovely smile  it's uh over what a start for our  generic icy the 18 year old takes the  lead in the match against the great  lavon ironian  what a game funky was a word used by